yeah welcome to this video playing
Pendragon chess from Spain let's let's
play the Kings gambit again I have this
quite amazing score 5 out of 5 and
recent games here without really knowing
what's going on yeah this is the fog by
account again but I think this is the
right right way to play
or what the bishop III I keep forgetting
okay so i cannot i cannot take on c6 of
course hmm yeah probably i should speed
up my development and maybe try to get
rid of this this night we just died just
retreats interesting i take now he will
have some some nice development that
sits for sure but i cannot really allow
him to take take himself at least my
development is not bad he goes Bishop c5
yeah i can i can give the check here
check trying to irritate him
so we just retreated mm-hmm Jim probably
just castle I'm um yeah I'm pawn up he
sacrificed a pawn and I'm not so sure
that this is really compensation only
have this issue of slide slightly am
hampered development here with the pawn
on f4 and 92 if I get in night d to f3
Bishop e3 something like like that I'm
in excellent shape and the night only
five is a very annoying piece yeah this
is why he probably tries to get rid of
it ok so just Knight f3 yawn I don't
have a tactic not really at least I
don't see one but this looks good
supporting the snide so
yeah maybe maybe this just get rid of
this strong bishop maybe you could have
taken twice iam
this still looks some quite favorable
for white I think green on c5 versa is
nicely placed and also threatening night
takes f7 one night f7 moog f77 Queen at
five just quite strong
hmm
if it just take it
hard to believe that this should work
maybe it is hmm if I retreat don't have
anything special weird
okay I'm still I'm still locked or
teenager Tim and I don't need five
I try to to place under a group / 27 on
97 it's technically a bit tricky but
dropped his happiness is a threat Rock
d7 rookie hive I have Queen takes off a
check so rock t7 I is a threat okay b6
hmm surprises me he had the knight on c6
are protected by the pond and now this
night is loose I don't really see a
reputation or something but it's a
tricky tricky thing rock d 70 rocked his
seven should be good night d 526 he's
got put our he can play 95 2697 this is
sick
yeah of course
I know 97
why not 97 yeah yeah this is so this is
of course this is probably even stronger
but completely unnecessary
yeah I don't see movement probably that
isn't there isn't any the queen is hang
and I have no way to protect the look so
like resign resigns yeah I just
blundered this away ok I'm going up for
for just absolutely nothing 96 or route
25 or whatever just not luke t 7 I
forgot assembly forgot that after Queen
e6 that this 95 takes 27 forgot about
the move yeah other than that it was a
pretty pretty straightforward game where
I was just better out of the opening he
misplayed this simply Chang he had just
good for what general the computer
doesn't doesn't really a point out any
any bigger improvement so I'm just
keeping the extra porn until I i
blundered away with root he said and so
a lot of the Kings gambit but the
opening was not to blame I had an
excellent position here thanks for
watching